hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch jedes gut ich hab was
meistens vor und ja ich hab das ganze
ein bisschen durchgeplant jetzt buchen
wir und dann geht's auch im
schnellstmöglich mal los ihr habt ja
sicherlich in den letzten wochen
mitbekommen ich habe hin und wieder mal
fünf sterne hotels getestet wir waren im
besten fünf sterne hotel in köln wir
waren im adlon in berlin das war's schon
noch und dann habe ich das nicht mal
gegoogelt und wollte das günstigste
fünf-sterne-hotel in europa rausfinden
also das war schwieriger als gedacht als
länder kam anfrage bulgarien rumänien
und die ukraine alles wirklich sehr sehr
günstige länder auch die preise der fünf
sterne hotels sind relativ ähnlich ich
muss sagen ich weiß schon wo es hingeht
flüge habe ich schon gebucht wir fliegen
übermorgen schon los und es gibt jetzt
drei hotels oder es gab drei hotels die
zur auswahl stehen da man jetzt
frühzeitig bucht kosten alle 65 euro die
nacht also wirklich nicht viel ich
brauche jetzt relativ kurzfristig
deswegen muss ich leider 80 euro
bezahlen aber wir halten fest 80 euro
für zwei personen ein guter freund von
mir kommen mit der leon dann werdet ihr
gleich kennenlernen muss das frühstück
ist schon im preis mit drin ich habe
mich jetzt hier für das hotel an
entschieden das ist ein
fünf-sterne-hotel so sind die zimmer aus
wirklich anscheinend riesige zimmer also
ja keine ahnung hier ist ein pool mit
bei
fitnessstudio alter dieses zimmer ist ja
riesig genau und so sieht das ganze von
außen aus das hotel ist in der
bulgarischen hauptstadt sofia sehr gutes
frühstück inbegriffen das frühstück
hatte eigentlich einen wert von 15 euro
also so gesehen bezahlen wir 50 euro pro
nach geteilt durch zwei also 25 euro pro
nacht pro person ohne frühstück aber das
kannst halt nicht buchen ein weiteres
fünfsternhotel gab es auch in varna dass
es am goldstrand auch in bulgarien was
ebenfalls 80 euro kosten würde oder hier
habe ich noch eins gefunden in bukarest
warte mal woanders das hat auch 80 euro
gekostet aber nach sofia sind die flight
connections auch am besten und ich habe
irgendwie bock das ist die bulgarische
hauptstadt und ich glaube das wird sehr
sehr verräter war ich auch noch nie
deswegen ich bin halt leute ich wünsche
euch viel spaß beim video und ihr seht
mich jetzt wahrscheinlich schon am
flughafen
kurz vor 7 ohne schon später alter sofia
einfach hat minus sieben grad wtf ich
habe eigentlich gedacht es ist wärmer
ist hier aber das ist einfach kälter und
morgen mit minus 14 grad oder -12
scheiße und dann waren wir schon am
flughafen leute hier kommt der flieger
und im jahr die flüge waren mit abstand
das teuerste an der ganzen reise mit
großem abstand
[Musik]
wir haben es geschafft zum ersten mal in
meinem leben in bulgarien alters hat es
nicht gedauert bis wir durch alles durch
fahren die nehmen es hier wirklich ernst
braucht ihr auch pcr test aber erst
jetzt erstmal ab und zu tag
also hier sieht auf jeden fall von geil
aus
[Musik]
definitiv ist okay 2 bei
also da kann man nicht weg kann 18 euro
gekostet umgerechnet ungefähr dann gehen
wir mal hier ein metzger
viel automatencasino 3
[Musik]
alexander
jäger wenn das in deutschland mal genau
so einfach gehen würden wie lange hat es
jetzt die dauert eine halbe minute immer
wenn ich in deutschland irgendwo
mithelfen dass du musst der erstmaligen
titel ausbringen fünf minuten lang
durfte wir sind auf jeden fall den motor
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wie der ts
für den preis also fotos seien die
zimmer auf jeden fall da gucken ob die
auch in echt zu großen
101 hier ist es doch schon sagt abfahrt
vom casino royal palms casino degas das
hat einfach das hat einfach die ganze
nacht aufnehmen und nicht dass du dich
daher für erstleser und erst first
impression erster eindruck
[Musik]
also in deutschland ich war letztens hab
ich habe letztens das adlon abgecheckt
tun wir haben sogar eine eigene küche
nicht mal da war das zimmer nicht mal
ansatzweise so groß wie groß ist denn da
ihr hey du kannst du kannst dir eine
miese sause machen alter ja hier immer
auf jeden fall das badezimmer und leute
für 40 euro pro person pro nacht mit
frühstück also eigentlich wenn wir das
frühstück auch noch abziehen 80 euro -
15 euro kostet das frühstück dann sogar
zwei frühstücks 50 25 euro pro nacht so
gesehen
krank oder samsung fernseher damit hat
der tür
und hier ist er so gut aus ich das nicht
so berauschend aber egal wer in der
minibar das ist glaube ich alles mit im
preis drin ach nee da steht mit
preisliste oder wir hier nicht das ist
glaube ich echt noch mal also dass wer
tipps und hier steht heute was dran oder
das kostet glaube ich was der schnitzler
das war hier ein sofa ich finde das gar
nicht so also es ist nicht zu 100
prozent mein geschmack aber hier kann es
auf jeden fall aushalten
eine sache die mir noch aufgefallen ist
hast du unten die preisliste gesehen
weil ich habe das zimmer jetzt über
pocking gebucht das hat so gesehen hat
insgesamt 160 euro kostet und da unten
stand für dieses zimmer allein schon für
einen 890 euro weist also wahrscheinlich
wenn du musst du online buchen weil
vielleicht gerade die nachfrage hier
nicht so groß ist ist es günstiger also
leute wirklich krass einfach so gesehen
ohne frühstück gut das haben wir mit
drin aber ohne frische drücken um 25
euro pro nacht pro person also da kann
man echt nix sagen wir gehen jetzt erst
mal ein bier trinken so erstmal ein café
ziel ist das ein whirlpool auf dem
badezimmer hier haben wir übrigens noch
den room service dann wollte ich immer
kurz zeigen können wir gerne bestellen
massage kostet ungefähr umgerechnet 40
euro für 50 minuten das ist dann gar
nicht mal so günstig das zimmer kostet
ja so gesehen genauso viel und hier gibt
es dann so sachen wie tomate mozzarella
salat für ja ungefähr fünf euro bisher
das meiste hier kostet 5 euro auf der
ersten seite leute hier haben wir noch
ganz wichtig das business menü drei
gänge menü für 12 euro salat hauptspeise
und nachtisch alter da kann man wirklich
nicht mehr kann und dann hier noch
zehn prozent gutschein auf alles was sie
hier bestellen zeit also das nenn ich
mal turbo günstig aber wir müssen
erstmal ein paar erfahrungen sammeln und
am ende schauen wir doch mal wie günstig
ist wirklich ist wir werden sehen leute
mal gucken was heute noch so geht hier
in sofia die situation nochmal einer
lobby ja so ein paar fische
und natürlich viel wichtiger das casino
ab und das würde ich sagen guck mal hier
war komplett plus hier leute wie sie das
hotel übrigens von außen aus und leute
wir waren leider jeden tag von morgens
bis abends unterwegs deswegen haben wir
im hotel ich gegessen wir haben uns oft
wie angeguckt wir haben ein bisschen
kulturelle einblicke gesucht und diese
auch vorzüglich gefunden dass wir super
da wirklich sehr lecker so etwas geht
die erste haben wir überstanden war sehr
sehr gemütlich muss man sagen ausser ein
problem dar und zwar und mir das fenster
nicht schließen wir es war einfach die
ganze nacht auf und schauen wie es hat
geschneit sieht aus wie im skiurlaub
zumindest ein bisschen
nämlich zum fünf sterne frühstück das
ist ja im preis mit drin 15 euro pro
person ich bin gespannt ist rock it
übrigens ich habe herausgefunden und
sein ganzes zimmer leer und das hat 55
quadratmeter 55 kassen ich muss
rückblickend sagen das frühstück vom
bulgarischen fünf sterne hotel war auf
jeden fall solide also 15 euro kann es
ja nicht meckern es gab eigentlich alles
was das herz begehrt cappuccino usa eine
wirklich große auswahl an der
bulgarischen gebäck croissants also
alles möglich ist war auch lecker von
daher kann ihnen sagen daumen hoch für
frühstück und jetzt wird es noch mal
ganz interessant wir hatten ja auch ein
schwimmbad im hotel sondern jetzt wird
erst mal nur ein kleiner schritt gemacht
wir müssen einfach mit badehauben da
rein das ist hier schon vorne hier sogar
world gibt macht ist kein wasser drin
bestimmt hat
muss das so
stimmt oder sony gehört
dort wollen wir die einzigen wir mussten
lustigerweise noch seine bade mütze
kaufen das ist da irgendwie vorschrift
ich weiß nicht ob wegen corona oder
generell weil sonst in die kalkulations
in bulgarien ja sehr überschaubar
deutschen ice kann man machen zum
schwimmbad muss ich leider sagen das hat
alles sehr lieblos gewirkt und
übertrieben nach chlor gesammelt also
das war echt nicht angenehm da es sei
auch sehr in die jahre gekommen aus also
definitiv mit einem deutschen fünf
sterne hotel überhaupt nicht zu
vergleichen aber das war mir auch von
vornherein klar leute was geht ab
schönen guten morgen wir haben jetzt
mittlerweile samstag also ja es ist ein
bisschen was verrücktes passiert ich
denke auf jeden fall jetzt auch aus dann
geht zum flughafen mein kumpel leon der
ist schon seit ungefähr der ist auf
jeden fall für zwei stunden schon in
deutschland gelangen werden jetzt
mittlerweile 11 uhr mein flug geht erst
um 14 uhr ich hab nämlich gestern im
flug für ihn noch gebucht und dann war
der flug einfach sold out du konntest
kein passagier mehr hinzufügen das ist
wirklich total dumm gelaufen und ich
fliege jetzt einmal nach frankfurt
dicker und muss dann von da aus nach
dortmund wollen was ja auf jeden fall
ganz cool leute ich bin mittlerweile
wieder zurück und der bulgarin reise es
war auf jeden fall eine super lustige
und interessante erfahrung wir halten
mal fest insgesamt bezahlt habe ich
jetzt für uns beide zusammen 367
bulgarische lever umgerechnet also circa
180 euro das lag daran weil die minibar
doch nicht inklusive war und wir haben
die immer leer geräumt im großen und
ganzen muss sich zu der bulgarien reise
noch sagen das hotel war super günstig
wir haben uns da wohl gefühlt das war
alles cool der service war in ordnung
alles wird immer neu aufgefüllt das
zimmer wurde jeden tag frisch gemacht
also unterm strich für den preis
wirklich ein traum was dann aber schon
negativ punkt ist also an manchen ecken
war es trotzdem irgendwie dreckig die
fenster waren so dreckig das kann ich
euch mal zeigen habe ich noch gefilmt es
wird in einem deutschen fünfsternhotel
natürlich niemals so aussehen und was
ich rückwirkend auch wirklich sehr
schade von also ich fitter nichts zu
sagen wenn das jetzt ein oder zweimal
passiert werde mit irgendwelchen
personen da aber das hotelpersonal auch
so taxifahrer und so die sind alle
irgendwie ich weiß nicht ob es deren art
ist aber es kommt oder es kann auch uns
so todes und freund über als hätten die
gar keinen bock auf uns wir haben hier
irgendwas gefragt und dann kriegst du so
eine katze antwort also was den umgang
mit hotelpersonal angingen taxifahrern
da hat man sich dann irgendwie nicht
immer so wohl gefühlt alles andere
gespräche mit einheimischen oder so das
war cool und wir haben echt einiges
erlebt oder das kann man doch ein paar
videos dazu sollte ich hoffe es hat euch
ein bisschen gefallen schreibt gerne
meine kommentare wo ich noch so
hinreisen soll abonnieren nicht
vergessen und drei leute